the dangerous and unhinged CPAC speech
wasn't Trump's only public declaration
at CPAC in Washington DC over the
weekend he also gave a very strange
Press Conference during which he came
out looking extraordinarily paled
disheveled and even visibly confused he
took a few questions and there are just
a few moments here that I want to
highlight for you one of the topics that
we've been talking about recently is
this loyalty pledge the Republican
National Committee wants all of the
Republican candidates to sign a loyalty
pledge wherein they will say in exchange
for being allowed on the debate stage I
will eventually support whoever is the
Republican nominee now we've been going
back and forth is that something that
Trump would be willing to agree to or
not one side is no of course he's not
going to agree to it the other side is
sure he'll agree to it if he needs to in
order to get on the stage but then he
won't abide by it well Trump was
actually asked about the Loyalty pledge
and at least for now he seems to be
saying I don't know there's some people
running that I wouldn't be big on
supporting so unclear whether that
loyalty pledge is something he's going
to go for let's take a listen Mr
President a lot of the people we talked
to the RNC has said that you might have
to sign a
State and their debates is that
something you would do or else well I
don't know I mean I'm just hearing about
it for the first time about the Loyalty
pleasure probably people that I wouldn't
be very happy about endorsing you know
running so we'll see I think some of
them I won't use names I don't want to
insult any but but some of them I would
not be very happy about so we'll have to
think about that yeah so Trump's saying
fundamentally and this is an honest
answer right there are people running or
potentially running or likely running
that he wouldn't actually want to
support so he's going to have to think
about it now I still think that the
truth is when push comes to shove Trump
if he absolutely needs to get on the
debate stage he will sign whatever he
will say whatever he wants to be on the
debate stage and if that's going to
prevent him if not signing the Loyalty
pledge we'll keep him off the debate
stage he'll just sign it and then if it
comes down to he loses the nomination
and then he wants to run as an
independent he'll just ignore it he'll
say you know when I signed it I didn't
assume they would rig it against me or
whatever I still think that that is the
most likely thing these pledges promises
they mean absolutely nothing to Donald
Trump at another moment Donald Trump was
asked about some of the things that Mike
Pompeo his own former secret one of his
own former secretaries of State said
during pompeo's own CPAC speech and
Pompeo said we don't need celebrity
nominees and Trump was asked do you
think Pompeo was talking about you and
Trump basically says I don't see myself
as a celebrity so I probably not
yesterday
was he talking about you do you have a
response no I don't think he was talking
about me I don't consider myself a
celebrity leader I consider myself a
leader of the country but I don't
consider myself a celebrity leader how
insane is this I didn't do this for the
celebrity uh maybe it helped me get
elected who knows who knows but I don't
consider that I consider
consent person that was President for
four years Trump doesn't consider
himself a celebrity of course the
reality is were Trump not a celebrity
celebrity he never would have become the
Republican nominee to begin with but
okay he can live in whatever fantasy
world he wants to live in and then
lastly the topic came up during this
press conference Trump gave
of if you are indicted
will you still run for president and
Trump said he would here's like a little
report on this from ABC Trump himself
faces multiple state and federal
criminal investigations and lawsuits but
he told reporters none of them will
force him out of the race even if he is
indicted
absolutely I wouldn't even think about
leaving well Trump dominated CPAC
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis spoke this
weekend at the Reagan Library okay so
Trump's saying he would absolutely stay
in if he is indicted now I think that
that statement is meaningless and what I
mean by that is Trump has no choice but
to say he would stay in because if he
says oh no no no if I'm indicted I'm
leaving he immediately short circuits
donations he short circuits support
because there will be people who will
hear that and say oh wait a second am I
going to support this guy or donate to
this guy
if he bails if he's indicted no so
regardless of what the truth is Trump
has to say he would stay in in reality
in practice if Trump is indicted
depending on what the charges are
depending on what's going on I think it
will potentially affect his race now
whether he actually bails or whether it
just destroys his chances of winning are
two different scenarios which we can
discuss at some future point but I think
Trump has no choice but to say exactly
this at this point in time and we'll see
what the truth is if and when it happens
and by the way reports are that the
indictment may come down anytime as I
like to say it could come down today or
never that's the range any time between
today and never Trump could be indicted
did you know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water sometimes I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com slash Pacman
the link is down below